Jim Acosta was sitting 10 feet from me
and he badmouth me saying I was a PR
stunt abut that I did that he played me
directly a PR stunt you get to promote
my pillow I'm Dave Rubin and this is the
Rubin report lockdown edition remember
everybody you can get all of our videos
totally ad free and early at Rubin
report comm and joining me today is an
American businessman entrepreneur and
founder and CEO of my pillow Michael and
L welcome to the Rubin report thanks for
having me on thanks for taking the time
my friend I've wanted you on for quite
some time and then over the last couple
weeks
you went from a guy that's kind of hard
to get to a guy that's impossibly hard
to get and now I've got you in a hotel
and we're gonna we're gonna take
advantage of the time so everybody knows
what happened a couple weeks ago with
you at the White House and and the
brouhaha and as I was saying to you
off-camera watching the media go after
you was so consistent with what I've
seen about so many of my guests who have
dared to take in an opposition opinion
than mainstream allows for but I want to
hold that for a little bit because your
back story what you've been through in
your life is pretty incredible and it's
a it's a true story of perseverance
actually so could you just I know you've
told the story many times before but
could you just back us up and and tell
us the Michael and Elle story and then
we'll get to everything happening in
2020 absolutely and by the way you
talked about a press event at the White
House at the Rose Garden I've had over
80 interviews now since then so it's
it's proud this platform that's God's
given me just huge just when I think it
can't get any bigger it gets bigger but
you go all the way back for my story
okay begins back I guess that you know
without my new book what are the odds
from crack headaches a CEO but it takes
me back to is I was seven years old my
parents divorced and that's when
divorces weren't coming I got moved into
a new school two hours away
and I was the only kid in the whole
school that was from a divorced family
and I felt like right away it started
manifesting I didn't fit in I would I
would do things I remember climbing out
of a moving bus window to show up and
jump into the ditch we had snow in
Minnesota luckily and and everyone that
you know they were the Wow can you
believe you do that it would be these
crazy things or I wouldn't talk to them
I was very shy in that respect I thought
but I thought myself that I you know
there's something different about me I
just felt different I didn't fit in with
any one group and and uh and this had
kept going on and on throughout high
school and you know if I'm you know
traveling anywhere if I'd be anywhere I
didn't I didn't even deep really in high
school because of because of that it was
so it was just this unworthiness spirit
and I think when I look back now but I
you know I was at my five year reunion I
worked the last two jobs I had back then
I had up I worked for someone I worked
in a grocery store and a drive-in movie
theater if anybody out there don't know
what that is it was a big theater we
pulled up I went to one drive-in movie
in my entire life I saw a Robocop in
about 1989 or so at a drive-in I worked
there for seven years and Isaac it was
for the number one place to work back
then by the way if you were to work for
someone and it was fun but but anyway
and then I went to college at the U of M
in the first quarter I dropped out I was
still working the two jobs and then I
just dropped out and ran away you know I
was so I was addicted to compulsive
gambling and I started drinking about
seventeen actually late for you know
sixteen or seventeen but the we got to
our five-year reunion and I remember
getting there and of course I was
probably high I've been drinking and are
not and anyway the all of these guys
said either started families graduated
from college started their careers or
they kept the same job and moved up the
corporate ladder already so I was upset
with myself and I was a
where I was where I knew I could be
everybody was ahead of me I thought wow
I am you know well what I did is I took
over that whole reunion and told him
about all these toys that were true I
made with the mafia money $20,000 they
came to break my arms for football bets
I had when I was 17 I got like 18
tickets on it on a motorcycle in two
days outrunning the cops you know I went
to go skydiving fell asleep on that
motorcycle crashed it was bound and
determined infinity I was all banged up
and bound and determined to get down to
Staunton Minnesota and finish this
skydiving jump
it was my ninth jump and my parachute
didn't open I have a streamer hit the
ground and all these things but I'm
telling everyone at the Reunion and
they're just go wow wow well nobody I
didn't hear anything about anybody else
but I got home that night and I laid a
bed that was just a deep sadness came
over me that I really wanted what they
had you know and I had felon into this
thing it was like where's my life going
and and you know well then it's about
1982 or 83 you know I did different
things I then it was became a card
counter a professional card counter on
my uncle I worked on his farm raising
pigs I guess that was the last job I had
for someone and I just said well I'm
gonna raise pigs myself and I why am i
working for him so I wouldn't bought all
these feeder pigs put him in a semi
residential area and the bottom fell out
of America that was a disaster so but
the I bet I tried all these
entrepreneurial things on the sea
parallel track as I tried cocaine and
when I tried cocaine it was instant
I could be where I wanted to be I had
this false courage I had this you know
that mask any pain I had I felt like I
was on top of the world it didn't matter
what anybody thought of me I was you
know I felt better about myself it was
all these big lies but but I was a very
functioning addict then propane act for
20 years and chill it switched to crack
in the early 2000 but during that time I
ended up getting I married the girl of
my dreams I have four kids a very
functioning addict and
you know addiction affects everyone no
matter how many Forks you eat with
people that say all their addicts in the
street that's what they perceive an
addict at well of moisture Alex I hate
to say it are functioning there in the
corporate world or in the the you know I
was afraid of talking to anybody the end
suit in attire I wasn't as good as them
you know but but they were did just as
many problems as anybody does well
anyway the it got to beat it was always
an entrepreneur I end up having a bar
for 13 years and that bar would probably
have bad place for an addict but but I
am I tried different things in the bar
you know I learned a lot there with the
entertainment in Amman and advertising
and stuff you know different things a
lot of the stuff I learned there you
know I'd learned you know the
Entrepreneurship I really didn't look up
but also as a bad place for my
addictions and they switched to crack in
the early 2000s and then I could not do
what I was doing with the bar anymore
because cracks a different drug it's not
a social drug you're tweaking out
windows and and it was some it took all
my friends down the round crack very
fast and I said I'm never gonna be like
them and and I ended up one of the worst
ones if there is such a thing but in in
2000 was about to so I had to sell the
bar in 2003 and that was a that was a
circumstance beyond my control but it
was going down anyway was going down the
backside with the crack and about 2004
in the middle of the night when that I
had a dream of the name my pillow now I
had always my whole life searched for I
had problems with pillows when I was 16
at that grocery store I actually had a
went out and took one of my first
paycheck so we don't looked around you
know Harken store and bought a $70
pillow in 1970 stuff that's a seriously
expensive pillow adjusted for inflation
most expensive pillow I can find but
it's kind of this kind of you know what
a but strange and I buy the pillow we
back down to where I'm at now but I
tried it it didn't work I couldn't
return it and you know
just remember that was an endless search
for pills but anyway had the stream of
my pillow the name and I got up and I
brought it all over the house connecting
the Y and the P and I'm all excited one
of my daughter's comes upstairs about
2:00 in the morning
she's like eleven twelve so she goes
what are you even doing in I said I'm
gonna bet this pill it's me called my
pillow what do you think of the name
it's gonna change them millions of
people it's gonna be the most the
biggest thing ever and I didn't even
know what was gonna be in it yes she
grabs a glass of water she goes that's
really random dad but I just I went
all-in I was just like I kept getting
these dreams and you know what I wanted
was something you could adjust and now
me and my one son forget out today you
get home from school and we would tear
and try to I think we tried over 94
different kinds of phones and things to
go in it
nothing did what I wanted to it and but
we just want to give up on it and keep
like friends or laugh and they're going
much good invent the pill though uh uh
and the other ones would say hey if you
ever come up with something like that I
might want one
well I took about a year year and a half
and we finally had it done and I you
know I was so we had no money left
well we had some pillows enough I took
out the first one I went into a Bed Bath
and Beyond
I remember going in there bringing it in
and going where's your manager was over
there I'm talking to my go hey I got the
best pillow ever you can move it in just
and I didn't really know everything you
know I said you can worship right but
I'm telling them all this I'm so past my
how many you want I didn't know anything
about retailers sell you go Sam we have
one buyer and you don't and he's not
here no where is he
we just won national I was so persistent
and passionate he goes you need to leave
now
I go no really how many wanted ID now
and this is the way we're a closed door
one after another
nobody wanted the pillow nobody wanted
my pillow smoke but someone said Mike
why don't you do a kiosk I said how do
you spell that
yeah and I actually went to the kiosks
and I found out something there I was
really out of my element because yeah it
could be on drugs and you know the
selling or being you know which I did
which one of the things to when
did sell a pillow all this time I never
broke trust with the promoters that's a
key thing but anyway so we rented this
kiosk city in Prairie Minnesota and I
couldn't stand it talking to people
straight they come up and so it was just
yeah it was shy it was just like I
couldn't control kit and I'm actually
hoping no customers would come up you
know it was kind of weird well my wife
at the time she worked most the hours
but the one day I did work the guy came
out very aggressive he
he buys one he says I said you got a
business card he said this is really
unique you and you gotta invent to this
you got a bad moment since Penn and he
and he I said oh I'm all out and I wrote
it on a piece of paper gave him the card
or gave my number and I remember the PS
being such a failure and I ended up
doing um um borrowing money for
Christmas presents we had her my host
mortgage we had nothing left but we have
three under pillows and that's all we
had left everything was gone and and
that guy called around January 7th 10th
year and he goes are you the guy that
bedded this pillow in Minnesota and I
said yeah he goes well he goes and I
knew I knew I wouldn't get my number one
guy he goes well I run the Minneapolis
coma Garden Show and I save a spot for
innovative products this pillow
I've never seen I've been sleeping on it
it changed my life Wow
you know I said yeah okay I'll come in
and I brought money to actually get into
his show and but I got in there and then
they put a table up I put a table out in
front of me so the people couldn't come
in the booth so I was gonna felt more
secure like a security blanket and they
came by and that first day I remembered
I changed the boots that I did the
selling and it was it was easy for me
then cuz they were coming up and I had
an agenda I would tell him just X amount
there was no small talk and and they
would go by boy I was telling him that
first day every single one of them
almost I think that first day they came
back the next day got back into the home
show and told me came up and said you
know wow this pillow did this and said
help me sleep and all this and it wasn't
about the money for me for the first
time I felt so good inside that I had
done
something to help somebody and and this
sound this ties in with you know
addiction everything which I can tell
you in a minute but from that point on
that started seven years of doing home
shows and fairs you know going town to
town throughout the middle then
throughout the US and you know we'd make
them and sell them at the UM at these
home shows and fairs and just hours and
hours of work and some shows would be
good so socially bad but but I'll track
you know crack cocaine and another
addiction well and then people were
taking the company there was so many
that were tacky trying to take the
company that we'd have we'd have some
workforce was different people you know
coming into you know they seen something
there but they you know I did I did get
the patent and now but there were copy
they were trying to copy it everything
else we ended up making pillows we were
got to be 2007 we were labeling him in
our living room and I never forget
looking over at my wife at the time and
my son one of my sons and and I knew
that had gotten so bad we were gonna
lose everything cuz these guys we're
taking the company without the houses of
the lights were gonna go out on the
house we were losing the house and then
my wife left about two days before the
lights went out on the house she
couldn't take it anymore and so I went
through got the got a divorce lost
everything there the pillow was just a
little blip on the radar and and then it
got to be 2008 and significant things
happen in 2008 but the pillow company
was just like a pulse like somebody with
a coma and when one of the things and
one of the significant things it was
sport I was up 14 days with no sleep in
Minneapolis and I come out of the room
and all three of the biggest drug
dealers are standing there like what do
you guys doing you know each other they
go we don't love each other and they
said you've been up for 14 days you're
going you're not getting any more crack
and I said what do you just an
intervention the guy goes call it
whatever you want well two of them left
and I said there's how much you got left
I showed
moments Roxon he sat down to make sure
that I did it went to bed when getting
any more well he finally fell asleep
right about the time I was running out
and I was tweaking it looking on the
floor fur carpet call it farming looking
for crack use but never his crack there
well went back downstairs we headed
outside at 2:30 in the morning and it's
like bees in every city in the country
you can get cracking you get drugs
anywhere you're out there like bees it's
like a whole nother a whole nother world
and I'm out there offering money you
know twenty dollars for a five dollar
Rock nobody would take it they're
looking at me like what are you crazy
we're not selling to you you wait where
we you know they threaten anyone on the
street if you sell to them we're gonna
kill you everyone who knows well I came
back upstairs defeated walked in there
and the dealer says he's robbed no he
says how'd that work out for him he says
give me your phone I'm gonna take a
picture and he took a picture he said
there's for that book you've been
telling us about you're gonna write
someday he goes man you've been telling
us for years that this my pillow is just
a platform for God and you're gonna come
back someday and you're gonna help us
all out of this addiction world that we
live in and we're not gonna let you die
on us I was their hope as I told him
that all the time here's the extra on
that book the actual picture it goes
into a hologram you see the bad picture
there unbelievable
unbelievable but then on there so that
was the picture taken in 2008 and then
to where I am now and that and by the
way two of those guys work for me now
they're born-again Christians and none
of them sell anymore so I'm cut it's
come full circle but that year my son
was crying in the driveway
you know he got back for his tear all
cheered up he said he's 18 he said this
was another place we were in to lose it
he said I go you're coming in he goes he
goes no dad I can't live here anymore I
thought it was hiding it from them
you know and I just said I'm quivering
on because it's breaking my heart and I
said I said yeah you can go live with
your brother you know what there's no
problem and it just like hit me like you
ain't hiding it from anybody and and
then my son or my this guy came in
December this is really key to my lindo
recovery Network when we talk in a
minute my friend came in December there
was nothing left I was sitting in the
house all the fur everything was gone
and and he said dick comes walking in I
go dick what are you doing here
now he was my equal we are the same age
we both started cooking at the same time
very functioning Alex he switched those
switched to crack about the same time
and he had quit four years earlier and
fell on the Lord and I've heard about
that and I'm gone but here he shows up
and I go dick what are you doing he goes
like you're the Lord led me here he goes
what's going on I go well as long as
you're here I got questions for you I
said first one was is it boring
he goes no man in England and I drilled
him for an hour then drilled him for an
hour because you know what yeah I
respected his answer because he's been
where I'd been and he had made it
through somehow he was like my eye
caught my hope match in my book well a
month later I ended up quitting I said
in January 16 2009 I prayed I said okay
god I press nothing left I made sure I
didn't have any money or anything so
that you know they say was that your
bottom it wasn't really my bottom you
know I think I could have survived
without money
but I knew if I went without one more
day if I went one more day I would have
two courses on my life one would be my
calling where I'm at today and and if I
did if I went one more day that would be
gone it would be whatever real bead
would be like uh-huh on old Drive and
whatever the second feature would be
wherever that path was taking me
that's where would that's where that was
going so I pray said you know what I
want to wake up in the morning and never
have the desire again and I woke up in
the morning and all the desires were
gone now I did go to a faith-based
Center about two months later to find
out why I was an addict in the first
place but then things started happening
that these miracles I needed these guys
had taken the company and took all my
shows and I needed $30,000 I needed it
and I met these guys are I met this guy
this is oh this is just a story I tell
all the time
they this guy said oh I have some guys
don't take chance to borrow money or
whatever and I'd talked to him a couple
weeks earlier and so they I meant to me
I needed the money in the afternoon 30
grand and I was walking in there with a
t-shirt and here I walk in there's us I
don't know these guys from Adam here's a
CIOs eieio a CFO they're all wearing
suits I'm scared to death I go in there
with a pillow I go hey you guys I went
abroad 30 grand I'll pay you back 40
grand within two months I'm gonna set up
shows I'm gonna have the biggest it's
gonna be the biggest company in the
world someday these guys took my company
I used to be a crack cocaine addict and
one of the guys said the CFO I think was
what we need to quit crack and I said
last Thursday left the room it's like
shark tape for that reason we're out
yeah give me the money they didn't even
you know there was no they never check
my ID because I knew that cuz I didn't
have a driver's license so I walked out
of there with the cash ended up paying
back but things like that kept happening
for the next two years I got up - when I
did that I said my friends and family we
had no money left again and I said you
guys if we all put in money I want I
have a dream of the biggest infomercial
ever if no box stores gonna take us
nobody's gonna take us because everybody
that bought it at those shows loved it
and he would tell other people and and
they so they put their money and we were
told by these there's out these
professionals when Oh infomercials don't
work it's just to get into the box
stores I said well the box stores don't
want me and I don't want to go there I'm
gonna do it my way and they said oh it
won't work you need an actor and I said
I want to do it like I did at the show
with a real audiences that make things
real the infomercial launched at 3:00
a.m. on October 7 2011 I was living in
my sister's basement everything I had
was unbaked on that cook that
infomercial and it aired and I had 10
employees no we had just phones that we
were taking that we had you know
everybody taking falls out of my friends
or whatever at end and within 40 days we
had 500 employees it just exploded I
built my own call center we have we hire
people off the street they go Mike you
need to be CEO I do I need to be see all
this make pillow they go we get an HR
department I know that sounds horrible
we need a corporate attorney I said
birth and we never missed a beat we
never missed up we every everybody got
their pillows on time for my pillows on
time for Christmas but it just went oh
alright there's so much there but I want
to focus a little bit on the fact that
it seems like you found your purpose in
the midst of an absolutely chaotic time
in your life
sounds like personally family obviously
the drugs and the rest of it when you
look back now do you think you needed
all of that craziness to actually find
the purpose that now is clearly having
you live the life you're supposed to be
living well you know you see me wearing
my cross on TV all the time and I was
and they even weren't when they did have
it on TV and I would I would I would
always tell my friends after the bar
closed back in the day I would tell them
about hey I read about Revelation in the
Bible when I was in jail and I'd be
witnessing to them I didn't have God or
the Lord first relationship
those guys would quit that day
twenty-eight people quit during those
years and my friends are gone what do
you say to them losing friends well it
was all those times because I had 14
near-death experiences that would run
through in my book I have things that
only you go there in the book it's like
what are the odds when you have a
one-in-a-million happen a
one-in-a-billion or this this is you
push this up just a chance when you add
them up in your own lives when does it
become a miracle for me I used
mathematical odds that God has to be
real because we always thought that
happen he was impossible and the then he
got stopped my actual day that I did a
full surrender get this February
February 18th 2017 I mean so this was on
you know that's just a few years ago but
I am I always had faith but I didn't
hamburger to answer your question
everything that happened to me I say it
all the time I would not change one
thing if it's not where I'm at right now
because that that convinced me that God
was real and I just turned it over to
him full surrender and now I can go out
and use my plan
I don't have any worries I don't have
any you know if I put all my faith in
God and I could go out and and do these
things my evangelism things to help
people that's what I do this wasn't
about selling a pill it always has been
my pillow was the platform and that's it
yeah you must have had people from the
outside probably lawyers PR people the
rest of it that must have been saying to
you Mike you know the pillow is great
and all you can keep selling them but
you probably shouldn't talk about the
story that much the crack that much
religion that much the other things that
clearly are the drivers behind you but
did you just ignore those voices all the
time and I'm sure you still hear them
now yeah when I first first started
happening when I wore my cross on TV I
was up in Canada on a shopping channel
and it was I was all by myself all
lonely whatever and it was just like
like I said still had that thing going
on where I couldn't talk to people and I
was just I'd rather be alone at that
time and anyway I was breaking every
record they ever had and all of a sudden
here's somebody lady shows up and this
is a 24-hour thing it's grueling you
know you get to sleep for like five
hours
she walks in my room and she goes hello
I'm your executive producer and
congratulations you've broken every
record here in Canada but I need you to
take your cross and tuck it in your
shirt or take it off draining for the
rest of the time you're here and I
looked at it I said and when I sat and
she goes that's religious prejudice
against other religions or something
like that and I just went on a rant I
still a little anger issues then then I
go and I just flipped out and they said
because I wanted to leave anyway I'm
going it was like like the movie My
Cousin Vinny when the gal wants is they
for your right goodbye
you know what I go you're right I'm out
of here that cross the stand there so
either you like it or not and she
stopped and she just oh he goes well if
you feel that strongly about it I guess
you can leave it on and this is the
thing I fought with that people used to
call me when I was the only person
taking phone calls doing them home shows
and stuff and I did a little public
access TV station and they people would
call up and say they're wearing your
cross on TV and they'd be maybe atheist
be Christian slamming before it you know
it wouldn't did didn't matter and I'm
going I would argue with them it wasn't
about selling a pillow that I'm arguing
about and with them and telling him
things in the Bible again and things
that happened to me that couldn't it
couldn't have been any other explanation
they would find Jesus and hang up and I
don't take that how do you like me now
and I'm still coasted you know it's
funny I'll skip ahead I gotta tell you
this now when they say boycott Mike
Glendale and boycott my pillow on the
trolls of both sides better the other
people say all the time don't boycott
him he goes he'll double as else we see
another bad guy I mean that when we get
in a little bit - what happened to you
after the Rose Garden speech that was an
interesting moment because I saw a ton
of that all you know the media is going
after you and then you look at what
regular people are saying and they're
like yeah I just bought a pillow I just
water people pillow people are
screenshotting receipts in the rest of
it but I want to talk a little bit a
little bit more about the business
specifically because the idea that you
did you know the on-air infomercials and
that sort of thing and that and that you
still do them it's like there's
something there's something about them
like I the amount of times that I've
watched your infomercials or I remember
growing up watching Ron Popeil set it
and forget it and all of those things
that spray hair for some reason even if
you weren't gonna buy those things you'd
watch them there was something about
them do you think there is some sort of
magic to that beyond just being yourself
or whatever Ron had like what it what is
it about them
I think God's giving me this platform
and for me for my gift from God to be
able to speak and to have that that's
like my calling to be that it's a that's
beyond anything I'd ever imagined but
one of the things is we make them real
we do all our own commercials we have
other companies we tell them what to do
you know it's just me and a couple of my
people inside my pillow we make them
real and you know it's an anomaly no
products have made it sustainable on TV
every time you see a my pillow it either
breaks even that one exact one either
breaks or makes a little bit because I
don't need the other stores and stuff I
wanted I I did something that's never
been done
where we are you're making your directly
to the consumer directly to the to the
the the public and and one of the things
is is I think it's the realness of it
and and you know I've been on TV you
know 2.8 million times I heard that
number I had a fact check what you know
it's just like you know to me is beyond
anything I've ever seen but once again
that platform to get that platform of
trust and about you know realness I've
never you know it it's just this is what
we this is Who I am and I'm not going to
change and I'm putting it right out
there that's why I've always you won't
see one of my commercials where I'm not
wearing that cross and people like to
see what's real and they and it
transfers over I am who you see on TV
I'm not something different that's all
can you know most of the things you see
like the one Beck and the man in the
mirror once I'm over by the bed we used
we had one whole day of taping where I'm
over there with that couple and the man
of the mirror would know that commercial
and I'm going and I'm holding it and I
go oh you're gonna wake up in the
morning and dirt we just slept that
natural stuff in there people will see
me in the streets they go well well it's
just so it's just the jingle is so
powerful - that was that was cool well
it's just so obvious also that you were
ahead of the curve because now because
of podcasts and YouTube and everything
else almost everything in the digital
space is is direct-to-consumer right
everybody's using often code Rubin or
whatever it might be to sell their
products so so you through through going
deep on television you actually help
model something that now really works
online - well depends what you pay for
the online it's just like a TV out on TV
you know I'm very blessed all of a
sudden that I could not I could never
make or put any ads on CNN I'll say this
straight up I couldn't put any ads there
because they were still charging for a
bigger viewership from back in the day
so I could have didn't matter what I did
but just recently I was every to break
even on them so I'm putting them right
here I got one of their hosts saying bad
things about me and all of a sudden my
commercial comes up oh I might
how you doing we're Mike Ross and there
you go and that's pretty cool that
that's about as good as it gets okay so
let's talk about the CNN host and and
what happened over the last couple weeks
so obviously we're in the we're in the
middle of coronavirus President Trump
gives a speech at the Rose Garden
updating people on what's going on as
he's been doing pretty much every day
and then he brings you up
well first he sort of told people what
you were doing but you know what I'll
just tee it up to you I'll just let you
tell the whole story what was what's
that morning like did you know you were
going to the Rose Garden
I'm going back in time you have to know
what the part where I quit everything
and how did I end up with that me you
know be friends with the president
United States I think to have that you
kind of grasp what happened there when I
when I quit all my drugs and everything
by the grace of God I had never voted I
didn't know a liberal from a
conservative I didn't know a Democrat
from a Republican I knew nothing and
they didn't even care I think what were
the politics didn't affect me that's
what I thought
but when I came out of crack addiction
everything it was like coming out of a
coma everyone I look around what's going
on here
my friends are all unemployed they're
losing their houses I had already lost
two mine we got a president giving money
to an evil empire
we got half time above of some baseball
tournaments for Little League and
they're giving out first-place trophies
everywhere I go what is going on
I mean everything had changed up going
this is crazy
well anyway then you get up to 2016 I
explained a lot more in my book but I
get invited by Donald Trump before he
was president to cut to come to New York
surge of New York City to Trump Tower I
get there a private meeting on August 15
2016 now I walk in there it was just him
and I he goes Mike your way across you
go yeah
mr. Trump this is a divine appointment
and for some reason I wasn't nervous he
just was like oh wow is this it's a
normal guy you know and he started
telling me all these things about they
had told me whatever you do don't tell
him you are an extra crack addict that's
where the perceives I told them and by
the way I was an x-ray
you know I got everybody have this big
platform for addiction he goes I want to
wipe out the drugs I want to build a
wall they're pouring in he told me about
how you when to bring jobs back in
manufacturing back here to the US like
my pillow and he asked me questions
about that I mean I'm going that's kind
of oh he really cares
you have no agenda other than he cares
about our country a bit everywhere from
people indeed with four courts the North
fork's and I'll tell you one thing I
learned in all those years of being that
Peyer I could judge character and I'm
telling you he was there just genuine I
mean it was amazing I walked out of
there
a half-hour later and I go he's gonna be
the greatest president in history I went
to his employees because I couldn't
believe when I just seen talked to so
many of employees I want everyone to
listen to that everybody one of them
said great day they go what is this
really goes at least the best boss he
helped me out personally every it was
everyone you could same thing same thing
from a doorman to a court it didn't
matter now I go back to want everyone to
hear this I go back to Minnesota and I
tell my board I said you guys you know
this right in the heat of the electro
the campaign I Cho my boarded my pillow
I said you won't believe it
I said he's gonna help this country is
I've never seen anything like it it's
gonna be amazing
and then I want to do a press release
and I want to go tell them people on TV
back then I could do it I could tell the
media that I'm walking across the street
20 cameras would show okay my my board
said well I remember my corporate
attorney goes he goes if you do this
you're gonna ruin our company I got men
that went outside the office and my CMO
came out she goes we didn't get this far
by you not listening to God I go you're
right I went back to that Borman said we
didn't get this far by me not listen to
God because I felt it was my calling to
her mind you know that I had to back him
that it's when something I was divinely
supposed to do and so I did that press
release now I didn't even tell him what
we talked about you would think the
press would be Wow a Minnesota just you
know random guy that she has a great
story about me an addict and now he's
gotten salvation he's gotten Redemption
and he got to meet the Cookman could be
the president you know what
of them called but some of them did
contact me they called me a racist
they called me everything you could
think of the Better Business Bureau in
Minnesota took my pills ready from an A
plus to an F macabre it because I ran my
buy-one-get-one-free
too long because they that's their own
little internal whatever bars they're
not a bit you know they're no no they're
a paper play business they're not a uh a
bureau right anyway and then the lawyers
in California attacked me they went
after me for yeah
Oh kinda stuff have you ever experienced
anything like that I mean you had had
your own trials and tribulations but
have you ever seen just by oh saying I'm
gonna support this guy or I like this
guy to watch like a machine go after you
you read my book it's all happened me
but something like this where you're
going what did I do
you know it's like and then you you're
trying to destroy my dream this dream
we've gotten so big and you're trying to
destroy it all my employees that's what
my hurt angle they're gonna kill us so
employees that I had probably 800
employees are a thousand employees at
the time and they're just attacking and
we were in the news I get all would come
up even every newscaster when they when
they did this when they're BBB took me
from any plus to enough every news
outlet in the country I was the story of
the year and that was like January 2nd
2017 every news is out there it didn't
matter ABC NBC CBS CNN it didn't matter
you know and they're just slamming me
and sound biting me and making me look
terrible
and uh so I learned faster at what bread
away I said I'm only doing live
interviews because you're not gonna take
it
chop me up well but I've gotten used to
it I actually now it's it's over from
once you get past that it's too late to
close the gate the cows are on Bart
Idaho hunger and I'm not changing you
can sit there they over the past couple
years every time they say something
wrong on fox or do something there that
are they're not wrong but say something
that the that they don't like they'll go
boycott my pillow in Michael endo and
that's when they say don't boycott him
EO
well they could have told them before I
ever ties across the board on every
station if I had to pick and choose what
every when every host says on cable TV
and go all that that's subjective
they're going you know what I'm not
gonna put it out on you right there I
bet I bet CNN MSNBC badmouth me directly
and I still advertise you know I keep it
separate you know not only that you've
you've also doubled down when boycotts
have come on for certain host right
didn't win when they were really going
after Tucker weren't you the one that
filled filled the gap she was the first
big boycott that they did and we ran may
have right at the start of the hour I
was the only one basically for a while
there and you know because I couldn't
believe it you know what they were doing
their trend you're trying to tell me and
you're telling my employees that you
know let me see that you never see their
faces either you say you know the hidden
ones you know and other than you folks
that will say stuff but here's what
happened last week so we got a little
rerun here I mean I never thought that
my popular theme could go any bigger you
know whatever infamous babe whatever you
want to call it but I start making masks
I converted my whole company 75 percent
over to make a cloth mask and it was
quite a project we had to trade all
employees but we did it in like four
days okay can you just explain a little
bit about how you do that I mean did you
have to bring in like experts to change
machines I mean the call I made a call
to the vice president's office I
actually an email and they sent me right
away - Peter Navarro and and whatever he
was running I didn't know who Peter no
promise and then he emailed me right
back and he directed me to a task force
they had already set up at a little
coalition about anybody that was all
these different things from mass to
gallons or whatever kind of like let's
set this up so people can have their
questions answered so I called them the
first question I said one of the one of
the measurements is there a restriction
that I have to know about because
obviously I have to worry about getting
sued by frivolous lawyers in California
let's not forget that so I had to make
sure everything was you know it was
right in the meantime I already
I'm doing this so Mike my employees
they're very good at scaling I've had
some of the same team we're like a big
family we just started going we took
their sewing machines moved him made him
eight feet apart we had to uh had to
move racking we had to make sure that I
had to make sure that we had the right
fabric it was a blessing but my pillow
fabric was perfect for it we just had to
not do two processes of printing another
thing so we had to do a different
process but it wasn't a big switch and
then I had to get elastic at first I
bought the wrong elastic you know latex
so I just dumped that get the right
elastic there was a little shortage for
one day but I was determined I was gonna
get it and then we we had a biggest
really expensive cutting machine so we
could cut the patterns and we were up
and making masks in three days everyone
was training there I made like close to
10,000 the first day and we added two
shifts a friend of my week it's not him
had to be laundry the commercial
ornament we just I was up til 12:00
every day setting the foundation this
till midnight starting again at 5:00 in
the morning well then I get an email
from the vice president's office and
said could you come out to the and be
involved in a roundtable like I was
involved in one in 2017 first time I was
ever in the White House and for me to be
in America
well they said and we'd like you to help
raise some remarks I'm gonna okay they
got out of track I'm going what do I
need remarks for a roundtable for so I
actually the remarks are here these are
the typed ones here these are the type
remarks okay so I type him up and send
him out there and I wasn't even real
particular they wanted remarks of what
we were doing and uh pretty specifically
about what my pillow was doing I'm going
okay I don't really you know that's fine
I don't really need to brag about what
I'm doing to help the country but I'll
do it you know dad sits in a roundtable
and so I fly out there we get to the
roundtable and there's all the five CEOs
or that are there the vice president a
couple guys down at the end I forget who
they were and we go around the table and
each one well this one's doing
respirators that and this one's and I
said we're doing masked and but I wasn't
looking nobody was looking at their
remarks or whatever you know I didn't
even see any papers on
and I'm going something the president
came in and this is a good half-hour of
everyone saying what they're doing you
guys what you know what can you make
more you know but do you plant one of
your plans and and we get tired of the
president gets up and they all get up
and he said to the vice president we
didn't read our remarks he goes oh no no
they're for outside the president might
call you up to them they're really set
out but we go into the other room
towards the Oval Office and the
president he's showing it all the CEOs
kind of get a little mini tour here and
then he sits down he's got to read his
speech with the vice president and we're
sitting over here at this table and I
thought you know what I mean the remarks
like you know what I want to give a
message of hope to the people and so I
start writing on the back and you know
if you can see my scribbles there's
little arrows that go down and stuff
yeah we wrote it I thought I would
rewrite it on a clean piece of paper I
just get done with the last thing I mean
there's crossed out and everything and
they go okay we're going out to the Rose
Garden and I'm going what brother okay
so I and all I said was God please let
me read my writing the president calls
me up first I mean I came right up we do
practice just so I didn't know we were
all gonna go around the end so he called
me a person I went straight up so I
think they held the other CEOs back so
it's just him and I and here's a guy
that has so much nervousness of speaking
now I did have my um my throat I did I
had vocal cord surgery just a week
before so I was a little recipe like I
am now and and I get up there and I read
them and then I just felt you know let
it get short around I said you mr.
president you mind if I read something
off the cuff now he said yes and then I
read the guy you know God gave us grace
on November 18 or November 8 2016 you
know and just read that they don't
talked about that we are the nation had
turned his back on God and we should
spend this time animal you know reading
the Bible's getting back on the word and
spending time with our families and I
said we're all gonna get through this
with this great administration and
everybody's prayers and everybody
combining we're hauling this together
and we're gonna be
longer and safer than ever you were to
think I shot some okay so so you do all
this it's impromptu he's letting you do
your thing you talk about God you're
you're making I think at one point you
were making fifty thousand masks a day
right
yeah you're doing that right now so you
finish you finish the speech and did you
even think about it or realize what was
about to come your way like did it even
cross your mind no do you know what it
was just it was like to be if didn't
feel like you know agenda I didn't think
it'd be a shot heard around the world
and we won't we went back into the White
House and the first inkling I got that
it might be real big was the vice
president came to me and he goes he was
just wild like you know because you've
opened up the you know opened up the
heavens and he people are gonna you know
you're just it was just I don't even
remember what he said but he was just I
could just tell he just loved it I'm
going good I got a little confirmation
that it was okay you know the president
never said a thing about it you know he
was talking to the CEOs and us and and
we go except when I when I left the
White House I finally you got my phone
back see they have your phones right and
I'd open up my phone and turn it on I
had 750 text messages I didn't know that
many people had my phone number everyone
what did it happen I looked at Twitter
in there thousand words I looked at my
facebook it had blown up I had 2,000
emails I mean it was just and I'm trying
to drive and get to him going well I had
to pull over I was just going I call
them friends like what happened they go
don't you know everybody's talking about
it I'm going really and so for that
point I've done 80 some interviews as of
today every day all day I've gotten
calls from Israel my friends and
Australia they said it was on top of all
the news in the time on paper was the
cover of their national paper this was
like you'd think it was and you know one
of the good things there's there I'm
glad I asked the president because the
everybody knew he had no idea you know
he had no idea so
you know people that said oh you're
mixing church and state or Church of God
or whatever gotten got enough government
you know what I did that so what are you
gonna do put me in jail sorry right well
you didn't you also didn't the
government didn't force anyone to listen
to you people could either hear you and
and and believe or enjoy what you say or
not so be it
but now okay but now talk about just the
the media reaction cuz I'm sure you're
getting a lot of love from from nice
quarters and it must be nice to hear the
vice president say some nice things but
really I mean you know I was watching it
as it happened on Twitter and the amount
of of main stream media people who've
never donated a dollar giving up any of
their time they're all over my pillow
guy mocking you mocking Trump for
bringing you on it's a big stunt blah
blah meanwhile you're the one I mean it
cost you you don't have to tell me how
much but I assume it cost you quite a
penny to convert the operation not only
that but what you're then not making in
pillows because now when that happen
everybody you know we have laid off a
bunch of people that were on the road
doing home shows I have 90 some people
that do home shows and fairs like I used
to do they have lost their jobs because
they were closed at my stores were
closed well now they could all get up
they could all get on phone the calls
are still coming in but they could get
on phones now and with our business went
up like you say for everyone attack nine
people it's even more than I think for
everyone attack fifty people would go
after that guy what's wrong with you you
know I mean they would tell that guy
what is wrong with you he threw a great
things what have you done and these
hosts on MSN Jim Acosta was sitting 10
feet from me now and he badmouth me
saying I was a PR stunt abut that I did
that he played me directly a PR stunt
you get to promote my pillow are you
kidding
maybe you did listen right Jim I was
promoting Jesus I was promoting Bibles
and spending time with our families he
got it a little wrong there maybe he
didn't listen to the
listen to the first part of the speech
with every CEO went up there and talked
about what they were doing for the
country and Jim what are you doing you
know these two the things that was like
you know and then I went you know with
all this media but I was a good thing
because I was had a lot of media to that
when you cut you know I was able to take
the politics out of it we're all in this
together
I don't care if you're a Democrat
Republican you know liberal concerned
don't matter I went on all these all
this from People magazine juh The
Washington Post Fox I mean it didn't
matter and they they all saw their
actual outlets treated me right I mean
they actually treated me right there was
these hosts late-night host one
late-night host said we got Mike Lyndell
coming on tonight
from my pillow he's going to talk about
absolutely nothing and you know and
Saturday Night Live you know the course
they did their Alec Baldwin did his the
mess he is he did you saw his um you
know mocking but all these so what I say
is this and they told the president this
I did tell him this I said you know mr.
president I said these press releases
that you're doing are these free press
conferences they said people are seeing
how you great leader you are and I said
his rating is up 60-some percent but I
said I'm gonna read you something that I
said this guy's a friend of mine I've
known him all my life and I said he sent
me this text then it said Mike you know
I'm not a big tongue President Trump
then he's a he's a never Trump as what
he is it said but but you know what god
bless him he's doing a champion of a job
I think he's turning me and you know
what what's happening is the whole
country is is coming on board and they
they're gonna see that having a
pragmatic common-sense president who's
an information vacuum cleaner takes it
all in who what other president would
take and listen to private sector people
take it in from listen to his cover
listen to everyone before he makes
decisions but when he you know the guy
it's amazing having a businessman I
don't call it the Republican Party he's
changing to the the common-sense party
you know if I had to look at politics
before he took in there's things of that
party I didn't like he said buying the
whole thing this is the way it should be
for the people and I want to tell
everyone
out there to that he tell you when I
left the White House that night I had
more I'm gonna I'm an optimist like you
wouldn't believe but I'll tell you what
it went from here level two to level 10
I mean the highest it could be because
you know what I was seeing the same
thing I've seen before he was doing
making a decision here some some
governor would have took him six months
to do some he did it in four days he
said let me take care of that let me
take care of that we have somebody
that's making decisions not based on
politics he's in the back because we
need to save lives but we need to get
people back and said it's the biggest
decision he said the other night ever
well you know what you got to do this
every politician most of them I met and
I met him on both sides these career
ones that are out there they've all
their lives they've made decisions with
their own agenda it seems like and they
don't have the people's back and finally
this is what's changed and even people
on the Left I don't care but if you're a
liberal or a program whatever you are
you're seeing that this is the
common-sense thing because this
president knows problem solution but
he's got a god-given talent to know what
it's gonna manifest to to help each and
every one of us great joy to our daily
lives that's it so as a guy that went
from an optimist to now you call it a
super optimist in the midst of this
craziness and then clearly clearly
you're loving life right now and things
are good and you're still producing the
masks as you just said you had a certain
luxury in that because you know you're
successful and not that they couldn't
have taken you down but you had a bit of
a cushion there too to weather a storm
what would you say cuz I get this
question all the time I get this from
college students that they're afraid if
they say one thing that goes against
what mainstream wants that they're gonna
get destroyed what would you say to a
young person that wants to stand up but
but you know doesn't have that cushion
or even a family that's going to defend
them or worry that they're gonna lose
their job or the rest of it right well
you know what we're getting through that
if I just gave you advice three and a
half years ago I've been said you know
what and find you I'm scared too I'm me
and I don't ever back down and stuff but
but now I say you know what it's
happening all around you now they're
there this
all voice we have to all rise up and be
that voice you speak out your business
will be busier if you speak out for what
you believe and you don't back down to -
evil - - you know you're going you know
in the end you know what when I said
that about can I being taken out of our
schools and colleges I meant that I
think these young people are looking for
hope right now is the time of the
greatest revival in history we have
people out there looking for hope
looking for some what's wrong with Jesus
what's wrong with faith and and then it
appeared add it to your home I want to
bring this into because that's what my
book is with my addiction if you're an
addict in your home right now and you
can't even get out or whatever you're a
quarantine whatever it is and you you
know what you've all known everybody
knows before this this massive deaths we
were having from from heroin and from
fentanyl and stuff it's horrible it's
not in but you know what you ought we
all know that know if you're 22 opiate
addict or hearing it you also know any
of your friends that made it through
your own age just like I told you about
my friend dick then came to me now is
the time to pick up that ball while your
sitter and reach out to that guy and say
you know what how'd you get through
how'd you make it
that's Kim those questions you can't get
in a treatment center ask him the
questions that's the beauty consoling
you and on the opposite end if you're
somebody sitting at home that's made it
through had your hearts restore you
probably went to a Salvation Army team
shell and union gospel a faith-based
treatment center that works the secular
ones success rate I don't want to get
into it
there just to take an insurance money
and it inputs for me but anyway if
you're if you're someone that's made it
through now's the time to reach out to
people you know that are that are that
haven't made it yet they're still on
drugs they still need their hearts
restored they have wounds maybe their
father Lester went through a divorce or
never had a father like you know that
affected me in my life addiction comes
from childhood
fatherlessness wounds trauma
anyone that says tells me oh it's a
disease I don't believe it I've seen it
too many times where this happens that
it manifests into usually an addiction
to mass pain reach out to those people
and it will make it the biggest a
in the history of the United States all
they will use Jesus has our higher power
not just some made-up higher power and
it'll be amazing and these uh this is
what I want everybody to know we're
gonna get through this and when we get
through it we're going to be just like
9/11 9/11 we were safer and more secure
if 9/11 hadn't happened
it's a horrible than it happened but you
know what we were we were so vulnerable
to terrorism and that we and now you're
going to into an airport you're going to
arenas and you're checked you know
they've metal checks and everything well
now we come out of this it'll be
different but we'll be protected against
us against an unseen evil for a long
time to come and I guarantee that this
president what he's been saying all
along let's bring our manufacturing back
to the USA but let's bring the ones we
don't have to rely on China our medical
devices or medical things we need to
survive I got only two more for you Mike
is there any is there is there anything
that you haven't accomplished that you
want to accomplish beyond just
continuing the message that you're
trying to get out there
well this gifts over with I'm launching
the biggest it's called the Lindo
recovery network it's gonna be the
biggest not gonna help just five
thousand a year it's gonna help millions
I can't even tell you how it works we're
somewhat like that hold man I talked
about I've been working out into two
years I have millions of dollars my own
money into it it's gonna be the big it's
gonna bring millions of addiction I'm
not kidding this is the most amazing
platform I believe it's right from God
it's a divine thing the my boy what I'm
doing now my boy if I'm a bought my own
paper I printed three million copies I
self-published you know why because I
didn't want any middleman you're not
gonna find this out in stores this
understood I'm going direct to the
people because I'm taking proceeds and
this is what's you know what's gonna
work what's gonna help the Lindo
recovery network get launched to help
millions of people and employ tens of
thousands of events annex that have
gotten their hardest restore let me tell
you about addiction tell you one more
thing about addiction people you don't
have so many extra sex addicts that work
for me I'll tell you people say to me
all the time Mike you work so hard you
know wow you need to take a break you
know what I don't
I love what I do addictions hard work
any an adulterer where the hardest
workers ever when you're when you're now
you got it just to get the drug all the
things you go through and you know what
you get that person set free and they're
gonna set the world on fire they're the
hardest workers and there's great
entrepreneurs these great minds and it's
amazing so that's one thing I'm doing
and where that where the platform leads
I don't know
as I've spoke to a big stadiums 50,000
people stadiums for a guy that [ __ ] talk
US Bank Stadium in Minnesota
I spoke to 50,000 Millennials I did my
10-minute version of my story
and they had Christian bands and they
had big big evangelism speakers and but
people I've talked to probably hundreds
of the people that were there there was
mine story that resonated with them and
that's because people want to hear it
can only be in America and USA a story
where here's a crack addict that I'll
tell you this in 2017 when I walked into
the White House the president invited me
to I mean the USA Manufacturers summit
and I remember seeing a picture I was a
big Elvis fan a picture when I was a kid
of Elvis and mr. shaking hands with prep
then President Richard Nixon I thought
wow my Elvis got to see a president to
be next president it wasn't about Elvis
it was about well you got to be with the
president I walked in the White House
and guess what's on the wall that
picture and I'm going Wow and I'm all
it's surreal for me and I walked in and
I get back to this room we're having
this roundtable and I'm just it's
surreal for me here's this ex-addict I
sit down and my name takes there there's
no name tag next to me I said who's
sitting here he goes the president is he
came in and we sat down at a national TV
here's me sitting next to the president
all my friends have seen that said there
is no way this crack addict is sitting
next to the press in the United States
it can only be God because this isn't
real
it's just for me it's like I don't know
where the platform is gonna end but I
think we're in the greatest revival in
the history of the world and I said take
it we are gonna bring our country back
to God people back to God because who's
more
and when do people look for their faith
and they look for it when times are bad
and because they need to get through and
that is the Hulk and that's what I'm
doing my calling you know wherever God
leaves me maybe that time and I did go
by this with people that's what will
make you want to run for governor
Minnesota and all this stuff I'm I don't
rule that out because you know what I do
know that politics now that I didn't
know before I mean when our daily lives
that anything everything they do in
Washington affects what we do daily and
this is and I never knew that before
and I don't think a lot of people know
that they go that's just spots people
and argue back and forth no it's not
it's real and we're going through enough
I'll just give one last little thing
here what affects daily lines that
Network I'm sending out the Lindo
recovery network do you know there's
thirty some states that have laws on the
books that you cannot counsel an addict
unless you went to school per letter to
college for four years swam the English
Channel climbed five threes did three
backflips all this stuff what are you
kidding me
do you know who I want that person never
been an addict do you know who I want to
counseling me I want the guy that's been
there and made it through and that's it
so we've got I've got around I had to
get around all that just to launch my
network I mean these are things that
block things that could be so good for
us every day and and that's you know
that's where I'm at I want to I want to
RIT I want to get rid of this country
one of the things I'd like to do the
corruptness you got the you know you've
got the social media that the platform's
you've got the googles you got the
lawyers in California suing for nothing
all these things going to an
entrepreneur in our country they can
invent something it gets taken right
away I'm setting up a thing that's
another thing my store calm it's going
to be a safe platform for entrepreneurs
anybody copies one of my entrepreneurs
I'll never sell that place a pillow
again Oh Mike I gotta tell you as an
interviewer I know when someone's
phoning it in and I know when someone's
telling the truth and living with what
they're supposed to be doing because I
can I can literally feel it through the
screen and I think my audience can as
well
so I've loved chatting with you and
obviously we'll continue this on many
fronts and good luck out there and
you've stood up to the mob so you're
already good to go
I love it you know you know thanks so
much Mike appreciate it if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell